listen man I am a big fan of your work I
think I've said this to you a few times
that many times and uh the thing about
you so say someone has not seen anything
you've done okay obviously the holdovers
like let's skip that okay except for
that one which you're incredible in
interesting but what would you like them
watching first and why oh wow that's
really interesting I don't know that's
an excellent
question i' be tossup I mean I would say
this only because I don't know the first
thing but it's a movie I really enjoyed
if I'm going to cut out some of these
other things there's a movie I did
called The Illusionist that I really
like and for some reason I really enjoy
playing that character I don't know I
just I just throw that out there I'd say
that love that movie Neil berer did an
amazing job with that to cool over yeah
um before I get into the holdovers which
is one of my favorite films of the year
you are phenomenal in it thank you uh I
I watched every episode of billions big
fan of the show I did and so I'm just
curious what was your take on the final
season especially the finale and how it
all ended you know the finale was
fascinating to me because I think we all
thought it was going to be this blood
bath of everybody and then we got this
thing that was actually very kind of
measured and kind of sweet in some ways
at the very end you know so it was
almost like the biggest twist in that
thing was that it didn't end up in a
huge blood bath you know because I
thought I was going to take him out he
was going to take me out everybody was
GNA get taken out but that didn't happen
which I thought was really cool actually
I thought it was a really good finale
and it was like a fan you know it was
really good that's exactly what it was
that I was like I think it was for the
fans totally my my only nitpick of the
show and I want you to know I want want
your thoughts on this is that it's
amazing how all these people would just
meet up in like an office it takes like
four hours round trip the way my brain
works it's like I was four hours round
trip it takes it takes four hours to get
from Lower Manhattan to where to like
you know to Brooklyn I mean it's like I
was all over the place and one day I was
doing stuff that was like oh come on
this is impossible I can't get to
Brooklyn that fast you know was that
kind thing was very funny and especially
my character was traveling all the time
in a way that was just ridiculous that
that's my only nitpick on the show
because ridiculous you have to put these
actors in the same room but I'm like
this is a phone call this the chronology
of the thing was kind of hard to follow
sometimes for for us I'd be like how
much time has gone by how did I get here
why are we yeah there was a lot of that
yeah jumping into why I get to talk to
you I love this movie so much um it
feels to me like and I and I told
Alexander this like you guys shot it in
the early '70s and then they just forgot
about it till now that's awesome found
again somewhere yeah that's cool
obviously if Alexander calls you after
sideways you're probably going to say
yes but what was your reaction to this
script because this is a great character
it was a great character and the script
was really great and it all that kind of
prep school stuff was really great and
that kind of movie that it was sort of a
little bit reminiscent of the the
settings in Boston and stuff like that
but the dialogue was so sharp and it's
one of those things where you just like
I I know I don't have to do a whole lot
of work actually because the dialogue is
showing exactly where to go you know so
and the character was great all the
characters are great and the
relationship so you know I thought I was
like and it's a in my mind it's a
Christmas movie you know and and I like
and I like that about it it's definitely
a Christmas movie um so hypothetically
you and maybe pull an example from this
film but you have a big scene on a
Monday I'm just curious because I am a
big fan of like I said I'm a fan of your
work if you have a big scene on a Monday
you know it's an emotional scene or a
dramatic scene you know it's going to be
a little challenging
how soon before that day are you sort of
breaking down the scene or scenes and
thinking about how do I want to play
this and how you know what I mean like
yeah yeah no I know exactly what you
mean I mean that's a really I mean
that's a big question for an actor it's
like it's it changes over the years how
much preparation it's always a game for
me of how much preparation I should be
doing I'm overdoing it is not great
underdoing it's not great finding that
sweet spot I think as
I've gotten old older I've been a little
bit more willing to not be so prepared
walking in and not feel so like
everything is broken down and just
letting see what happens you know I
think when I was younger I was a little
B more worried about it and I
overthought it probably but it's a
constant challenge for for actors
sometimes and how you know the most
important thing is be relaxed more than
even prepared you know I mean and so
it's like it's just a constant journey
of finding where you can hit that sweet
spot yeah it's also possible that you
know through your career all that work
has now made it that you know that you
have muscle memory yes that's exactly
right and you so you can actually trust
yourself more and more which is hard was
hard for me as an actor and um I mean
somebody like Dom looks like he already
trusts himself a lot and that's great
you know he's starting from a place of
kind of relaxation and that's really
important so you've done to so many
roles do you remember what was the role
or performance whatever it might be that
you were the most nervous before
stepping on set on the first day that's
a really good question question I think
the John Adams thing had repeated
moments not just the first day there
were repeated moments in that show where
I was like oh my God this is totally
nerve-wracking and terrifying and so
that that had a lot of that going on
just because there was so much that I
had to do in that that I it was the
burden it was the volume of it almost
more than anything it was just like oh
my God how am I going to get through
this it's also not like you were in
every scene or
almost and and I was also it's also like
I wasn't the guy who was never shut up
either I mean I just talked constantly
in that thing so it was it that was that
was nerve-wracking all the time so there
are one of the things I really love
about this film is that it feels like
found family you know and there's so
many moments between the three of you
that are just so good that's nice you
know did you say that shoplifters movie
that Japanese movie I didn't but I know
what you're talking about it's a great
movie and and some certain point
somebody has that classic line of like
sometimes your real family isn't the one
you were born into it's the one you find
and so it it has that feeling of it and
what's really true about this movie
though that's actually really kind of
poignant is that it'll break up and I
know these people will never see each
other again and so it's like this moment
is really important for them but it's
going to go away you know and that's
which everything does I suppose
eventually but that's point in it's
weird you say that because I often when
I'm in an Uber now or when I'm seeing
people for the first time in a city
whatever I'll often end conversation
saying I really hope you enjoy your life
because I know I'm never going to see
you again that's intense and you know
doing what we do in film and stuff like
that you won't I mean you you form these
incredibly intense bonds and then they
break up and you really don't see a lot
of these people ever again and it's a
crazy way to live it really is um I'm
almost out of time okay uh the strike is
over and with billions rapping all of a
sudden your schedule is a lot more open
as it was so I'm just curious are you
looking forward to that freedom that's
going to come from being able to have
the time to like do almost anything or
are you thinking about like another TV
show for next year no I am enjoying the
freedom actually I mean I I I've I had a
guy described me once that I chain smoke
jobs so I I need to I need to quit for a
bit not quit but just cut back so I'm
I'm actually enjoying the freedom to
sort of relax and pick and choose and
see what happens I'm enjoying that I'm
lucky to be able to do that very lucky
so on that note I really want to say on
camera performance and this is one of my
favorite of the Year thank you I can't
recommend this film enough I appreciate
it thank you
man